this guy I just wish you a little bit
friendlier I wish is cuter I know
[Music]
hey guys guess what mayonnaise time no
mayonnaise let me try to find a recipe
or five mayonnaise without corn soy
oh my gosh it's like G amount this this
is made with not a couple of ingredients
couple ingredients it's really simple
and and you can tailor it you know you
can add a little more lemon juice if you
like it tart has a little bit of vinegar
in it you can add more a little more
salty you can really get creative with
your mayonnaise you could make an herbed
mayonnaise a garlic mayonnaise if you
like the basic recipe I'm going to give
you is just that and you it's this is
with safflower oil now it's an omega-6
fatty acid so you want to make sure you
know you also have your omega-3 fatty
acids and that would be your original
column oil that would be that would
handle that but to offset any omega-6
yeah so don't make your mayonnaise with
cod liver oil actually if you make your
manage with olive oil and they do make
mayonnaise it's olive oil it's a very
strong flavor I don't care for it but
some people do
I've seen it sold in the store some
people like it I like mine a little
lighter this is good I like it yeah it's
perfect and it's fresh yeah
let's just go back to the how-to of it
okay
[Music]
hey guys thank you so much for watching
please click the subscribe button and I
will see you in the next video